hey everyone this is kevin from the test
website comm and today we're gonna be
going over game number two from the 1971
Candida's tournament winner of this
tournament goes on to face buddy Spassky
in 1972 World Chess Championships our
competitors we have Bobby Fischer he is
the underdog facing off against
Petrosian who just lost the world
championship to buddy Spassky a few
years ago he feels like the title is his
a few years prior to that he beat buddy
Spassky and so he's looking to make it
three World Championships in a row that
he faces off against buddy Spassky but
he does have one roadblock in his way
and that is Bobby Fischer much younger
kid than Petrosian at this time Bobby
Fischer in this tournament had won 12
games to reach the finals of the
Canada's tournament and so Petrosian
understanding that his opponent has had
a good time so far feels like he's going
to dominate but in game number one Bobby
Fischer came out swinging in one game
number one so when game number two here
Petrosian has the white pieces looking
to assert himself as the dominant player
Bobby Fischer looking to stay aggressive
as always see if he can take a 200 lead
Patterson starts out with d4 this goes
into the grünfeld a defense with Knight
f6 c4 a g6 Knight c3 and then d5 now
White has a couple options here you
could always take here for the exchange
variation he opts for the safer
alternative and then is just bring his
Bishop here to f4 Bobby Fischer
continues with Bishop to g7 just fee on
Kenny when his bishop to the King side
of the board
III just solidifying this pawn chain
once the dark square Bishop is outside
this pawn chain pretty safe to play III
also opens up for his lights for a
bishop to defend this square here on c4
in case Bobby Fischer wants to take here
on c4
was he bad vision continue with a c5 and
then the pond takes and then Queen down
to a five this is pinning down the
knight here to the King can easily take
the pawn here on c5 if he wants to now
petrosian does have a few options here
the first one would be just to go ahead
and take with his
on here on d5 Clady didn't choose this
option this is a pretty drawl as' draw
variation because it tends to end in a
perpetual check after the night takes we
can see the Queen take you can just see
a lot of materials start to come off the
board after the pawn recaptures the
queen is forking the king and the rook
here the rooks gonna fall off the board
bishops gonna come here to e5 attacking
both the Queen and the rook here and so
we're gonna see the rook come off the
board after the bishop comes to e6 the
Queen can come to b7 but black has
perpetual check there's no way for
protrusion to do anything about this if
you were ever to come to g3 well that's
gonna be checkmate right there that's
not good so he's gonna come back to e2
and then we just repeat this entire
thing over and over so glad you didn't
choose that option other option he had
his Queen to a4 just says let's go
exchange material off the board that's
fine
I'll have my knight come here to a4 you
could play d7 force my knight come back
we kind of are just resetting the exact
same position except we don't have the
Queen's on the board and Bobby Fischer
has a few more pieces of elements at the
game so I really like this position from
Bobby Fischer and then the other option
is to have the Queen come to b3 it isn't
doing as much castle on the King side
and you can see rook over here to c1
Petrosian doesn't really want to play
perpetual check game doesn't want to
play an option where Bobby Fischer has
more developed pieces and he's pretty
much at the same spot as before except
the Queen's off the board that's not
what you're looking for with the white
pieces he chooses option D and that is
just to go and play his rook to c1 yes
Queen to b3 is completely fine it does
also stop this light square bishop from
getting involved to the game because
then the Queen is threatening coming up
here to b7 but decides for right now to
go and just play rook here to c1 Bobby
Fischer brings his knight down here to
e4 it's a great little outpost for this
Knight and then I can't take here it's
still being pinned down by the Queen so
Petrosian decides to go ahead and take
the pawn away that's protect
that night and that's exactly what it
does with paan takes here on d5 and then
night takes on a c3 and then Queen to d2
says this I'm gonna get this material
back you can't move your knight right
away I'll just go ahead and take your
queen right here so instead the Queen
comes down here to a2 this was protected
before by the knight here on C 3 as soon
as that comes off the board the pawn on
a2 is a sitting duck so that's exactly
what we see here
now the pawn takes does open up for the
Queen to attack this Bobby Fischer could
easily exchange material that's not
necessarily what he's looking to do
right here still trying to be pretty
aggressive I think in his mind he feels
like he's the better player he won Game
one he's now won 13 games in her own the
candidates tournament he's trying to
make a statement to the world right now
not really looking to trade off matil
brings his queen back here to a5 now
Bishop c4 Knight here to d7 Knights here
to e2 just getting the Knights involved
into the game and the Knight to e5 and
Petrosian has a couple options he could
retreat his bishop back here to a2 or he
could just go ahead and take material
and just say yes I'll give up my Bishop
pawn or bishop pair here after the
bishop captures here I can start pushing
forward with his pawn and this makes a
lot of sense if the pawn takes here yes
there's double pawns on the C file but
starting to get up the board and bobby
fischer's are gonna have to spend a lot
of time trying to make sure this pawn
does not push any further up the board
instead he decides to go ahead and bring
his bishop back here to a 2 this is
being protected by the Queen here on d2
still defending this square here on d5
just says I don't want to give up my
bishop hair quite yet
now Bobby Fischer had different options
I think even the better move for Bobby
Fischer right now is just go and take
this pawn here on c5 you don't have to
worry about any more
eventually Persians gonna push forward
with c6
but Bobby Fischer really likes to get
material involved into the game even if
it is a slightly worse move he just
feels like he has a better opportunity
with more attacking pieces that's
exactly does plays Bishop down here to
f5 let me see the bishop
here on e5 surgeon says yeah I'm gonna
go ahead and give up that Bishop pair
there's just too much material that
Bobby Fischer has in the center of the
board I have to do something about that
so Bobby Fischer now has a bishop pair
definitely something you generally don't
want to get Bobby Fischer Knight up here
to D for attacking the bishop and now we
see the Queen take here on c5 and says
yeah if you want to go and take my
bishop that's fine Bishop comes off the
board and then pawn recaptures here on
f5 so we do see black with the bishop or
the pawn the double pawns here on the F
file
Petrosian has given up his double pawns
here on the C file from Whiteside we do
have six pawns and then on black side we
do have six pawns as well but you can
also see that petrosian's toss a pretty
easy way to castle on the King side
Bobby Fischer does not so not a lot of
King safety here he has to be pretty
aware of the vulnerability that his King
has also does not have the best pawn
structure so if you're kind of looking
at what side is better right now it does
look like White has a better setup
heading into the endgame why decides
it's time to go in castle on the Kings
side the board followed by Queen to a5
attacking the pawn if the pawn moves the
Queen's gonna fall wants to make sure
that this pawn doesn't continue to push
forward this is a semi-open file with
the rook here on c1 so it's definitely a
threat this pawn can start to push just
a lot of pressure on Bobby Fischer he
has to deal with also just says hey if
this Queen moves I'm gonna go ahead and
take your bishop Petrosian continues
with Queen c2 defends all the same
squares also attacks to this pawn here
on f5 black pushes that forward with F 4
and now C 4 as we talked about before
pushing that pawn here on the C file we
see the pawn take on e3 petrosian's not
to worry about it he could easily
recapture if he wanted to but he decides
let's go ahead and push that pawn this
is my best way for victory Queen down
here to d2 Queen up to a4 says yeah I
don't want to exchange right now I have
a threat I'm gonna push it as much as
possible King to f8 we already knew
Bobby Fischer was not gonna be castling
on the Kings side so he just decides to
go ahead and move
is king here to f/8 and then rook here
to d1 attacking the Queen Queen to e -
and then pawn d6 putting a lot of
pressure on black here Queen to h5 and
this is threatening the Queen down here
to h2 and I think in this position white
almost freaked out because of that
because yes your opponent does threaten
mate in one but you can just play pawn
takes here on e7 check they have to
respond to that King here to g7 then you
could take with your pawn if they come
down here to h2 that's fine you could
play King f2 they don't have any more
threats right now they might want to
come back here at h4 but they can't
because the Queen just come over here it
is protecting the entire fourth ring so
that is probably the option he should
have gone with he kind of freaks out a
little bit decides to go ahead and play
pawn to f4 says yeah I don't even care
if you push your pawn to e2 that's
exactly what Bobby Fischer does
unfortunately for him it's not the
situation that he's thinking and not
really sure if he just didn't calculate
everything or if he just forgot about
this lonely piece over here on a 2 but
we see the bishop fall here on e5 pawn
takes here on d1 gets the Queen rook
takes here on d1 Queen takes on e5 no
real other option for the Queen to do
but then rook to f1 and now the bishop
and the rook are both eyeing down this
pawn here on f7 Bobby Fischer does not
have his other Brookes involved into the
game so it's really just the Queen the
bishop and the rook eyeing down the King
which is in the center of the board
versus Bobby Fischer's queen you can see
where this is going it's not very good
for Bobby Fischer he plays f6 trying to
stop the immediately immediate threat
here of the rook taking on f7 but that's
just met with Queens who be three
threatening again Queen up here to f7 no
real way to stop this we see King g7
Queen up here to f7 now the pawn takes
on
seven and the reason that's important is
that pom was protecting this pawn on f6
now you could easily have the rook come
here to f6 if you want you could have
the Queen come it another option as well
but then we see pawn to f5 says yeah I
don't want to have you take my pawn and
check my King here
rook takes Queen to a D for checking the
King but after the King comes to h1
there's no other threats that Bobby
Fischer has yes he could always come
down here to something like the 1 or a 1
but as soon as he does we see rook down
to F 1 this is stopping the threat and
it has protection from this Queen so
Bobby Fischer ends up losing petrosian's
got to feel pretty good comes back at
the white pieces has established himself
as the dominant player that he feels
like he is in this tournament so first
two games holding serve here everyone
that has white has won so thank you guys
so much for watching we're all tied up
after game number two we'll come back in
the next video and look at game number
three from the 1971 Kenna's tournament
between Petrosian and Bobby Fischer